hello everybody my name is markiplier
and what the hell am i doing wait oh
yeah I forgot my timer my phone timer
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome let's play lasting now this
is a game that I found on gamejolt
obviously if you want to play it in the
links in description below as always if
any time I play in any game links in the
description below it um it's a very low
res pixelated game kind of a really
creepy out of here right off the get-go
like I'm scared if you all remember that
okay left click uses the door haha it's
actually reminds me or more of hide in
terms of graphic quality than anything
the readme said you're trying to find
these diskettes so I just found one and
I do not like this place I mean it's
really really really reminiscent of you
know hide cuz the graphics are about the
same if you're not outside hahaha I do
like these games these style games
they're very you know they're very
atmospheric for what they are I mean
it's obviously a 3d environment but I
don't know kind of the way it is set up
at the moment kind of freaks me out just
a little bit more whoa that was eyes in
that arise in that trashcan weren't
there what was I am I going crazy
already oh boy
haha okay so there's a lot of doors
apparently oh okay it's locked
that was not more doors holy hell okay
this is an easy place to get lost in
can't go left
hello what's this now what's is these
trash cans am I supposed to do something
with them or is it just reminding
everyone to recycle him what El Al
papers
look like a body for a second I was
assuming it's low res so I thought that
might have been just out like a dead
body but no alas oh hello pipes I'm
guessing more doors Godley so many doors
good golly what was that what is that
what is a hug
what is that shut up shut up holy hell
oh man what is this a bathroom nice no
privacy toilets here oh no way these are
urinals okay all right I'm getting
steadily more unsettled the longer I go
I have no idea how to figure out how to
navigate this place because it just
seems to be doors I don't know if this
game is randomly generated or what but
uh but um but um but um oh hello this is
different
maybe I'll get lucky nope no luck more
doors
haha Oh
Siri American now I remember this this
game of the readme of the game told me
that I was not alone so uh yeah okay oh
hello yeah I like here we go got it - I
got - ha ha how many of those have I
missed if I haven't looked at the ground
huh ok moving forward
aha three hell's to the yeah making
progress like a mouse just waiting for
the day when I get my eyes clawed out
here so far so nothing can kind of
easier with it you know when nothing
happens after a while the dungeon can
only last for so long so oh hello what's
this what is this what is this what is
this ok to the door huh it's gada this
has got to be randomly generated ok I
gotta check the floors from now on
because apparently there are diskettes
lying around and random place in the
floor and I can't sprint apparently oh
so you just got to check the ground I
was looking for like on the trash cans
and around the chairs so nothing in here
okay wait no okay movin forward slowly
but surely that trash can look like a
head popping out behind a box for a
second I almost got worried whoa box
I don't know what these random objects
scattered everywhere let's see uh what's
the point
ah uh-huh uh-huh what's that four five
what was that
oh the thumb B is back uh-huh the thumb
P is back I'm gonna start closing doors
behind me closing I said closing dog
check it
never mind this is mere the rooms giving
god damnit holy balls
[ __ ] you oh my god oh oh I can't print
forever oh ha ha just close the door
close it close it no no door closing the
hole is different oh oh I almost ran
right into it I sprinted forward holy
ball arene oh my god those oh man oh ha
man hey oh oh oh man oh man oh man oh
don't do that again don't do that again
please please dear good golly my
goodness holy Frick and frack that was
terrifying
uh-huh ah another one what am i up to
seven now I think locked how many do I
need how many of these do I need how am
I supposed to put these in a computer
somewhere you're and you're randomly
generated everything is leading me in
circles here I don't know which way to
go where why or when
what am i doing I'm looking on the
ground for your stupid biscuits and I
wanna do why why am I doing this why I
do it okay okay okay uh-uh uh-uh uh-uh
uh-uh uh-uh uh-huh okay I'm okay I'm
okay I'm okay
another diskette around here somewhere
another floppy disk back to this setup
hey I keep getting stuck on the walls
here locked not locked no disk I'm weary
of these long hallways now cuz I'm
assuming that's the place where whatever
the hell that was will spawn come at me
bro come at me brah
broham o hallway after hallway that's a
bad sign isn't it that's a bad sign
that's a bad sign that's a bad sign this
is a bad sign this is a bad sign
okay back to normal no objects in the
room though kind of weird okay oh man
then music okay not fine in any discs
but it seems like it's giving me less
choices I never mind it just opened up
again I'm an idiot never mind
okay I'm not sure if I'm running in
circles or what or oh no not again he's
in here is it behind one of these doors
he's gone
what I can't I open this okay okay still
looking for like I think I've got seven
I think unless I miscounted and they
have six ma of eight I'm not sure but
I'm hoping that soon
look at all that I need I know I don't
know I don't know oh I want to go home I
want to do anything but play this game
huh I sound a bit like Beavis and
Butthead
oh no no no no no no [ __ ] you
Oh gah gah go round pug close the door
closing em Tory Oh who's that
did you open that damn door Oh God
I gotta go back every me it'll be the
damn door
it's not going to be able to know what
is our door oh oh no no no
no no no no no no no no did I go this
way I don't know oh no no disk disk disk
oh you know every hey somebody we live
oh oh no it's a sound it's a desk
oh that eight clearly oh no he's in this
room area oh god oh no I got eight I
think can I be done
could I be done please I want to go home
more doors are being locked now why
another desk oh god oh god are gonna be
oh let me go let me go let me go was
that one on the ground there I saw maybe
something I don't know no no I don't
know I don't know okay I'm okay I'm okay
I'm okay I'm okay I'm okay
okay I'm a mom a mom okay
I'm not sure if it's like channeling
y'all know you know I'm dead I'm dead
I'm so dead I'm so dead I'm so dead I'm
dead I'm so dead I'm so dead
no it locked me down that hole I know no
yo okay please please oh thank you thank
you thank you thank you
ha ha ha yeah oh God
boom or lock doors everywhere whoa huh
let me go let me go guy let me go just
let me go just take your disks and go
I'll give you the disk I don't care
about the disks whatever they are okay
okay okay okay he's not uh-huh another
one I don't know how many do I need only
we're in desc join ade what my objective
what my purpose what's the meaning of my
life literally meaning without meaning
I'm actually running closed out of time
so if I see the monster again I may just
let him get me just put an end to all
this suffering I'm going through
I think I think that thumping is all God
I think that thumping is definitely him
getting close her maybe her who knows it
might be a her but um but um but um but
um but um but um I feel like I may have
missed some discs in the beginning so
maybe that's why it's not you know
letting me win her I don't know if you
can win in this game uh-huh
come at me bro I'm ready for you my body
is ready oh uh okay it's gonna be locked
again
oh no not locked oh I'm surprised
actually that one is owned is not where
is this guy
come at me brah okay okay you're gonna
get me now you're gonna give me this how
it ends this is how it ends is this
donut oh okay all right that was in
incredibly incredibly not why me not
well-made I can't say well maybe because
obviously it's low res Bunning
incredibly well thought-out game okay so
you get some sort of ranking system I
went 131 rooms I got 10 disks so hot
damn all of you play the game try to
beat that I guess it's an endless game
so there you have it I could have gone
longer but that's my score so see if you
can beat it so thank you all so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye
oh that's it
got one